the last gran turismo game dropped in
2013 so by this point car fans are
fiending for the next definitive racing
simulator and Polyphony Digital has
finally revealed it I'm Tony this is a
game spot news update and this is
granturismo sport when it comes to Gran
Turismo everyone wants to know about two
things the cars and the tracks GT sport
includes 137 cars all of which have been
fully remodeled since gt6 they're put
into four different groups with a mix of
real-world and concept cars and each one
includes a highly detailed interior view
as for the tracks GT sport includes
almost 40 layouts across 19 locations
including off-road courses and the new
Tokyo expressway and of course all of
this can be experienced through both
online races and offline events
granturismo sport launches for ps4 in
Japan Asia and North America on November
15th followed by europe on the 16th and
the UK on the 18th as of now there's no
official word on a beta start date but
you can pre-order the game to unlock a
few bonus cars take a lap with gamespot
and we'll fill you in on all the details
as soon as they become available
you